pour une cinquième journée les
bombardements du régime de bachar
el-assad n'ont pas arrêté sur l'enclavé
de la gutta orientale faisons encore
plusieurs victimes dont des enfants ça
continue dit ce résident on vit dans les
abris en tout cas pour ceux qui en ont
il n'y a plus rien à manger nous sommes
devenus des cibles
plusieurs hôpitaux ont été directement
bombardé et mis hors service
vous pouvez voir la destruction de
l'hôpital dit ce médecin les patients
que nous avions ici sont tous dans un
état critique
nous les avons envoyés se réfugier dans
des endroits où ils ne peuvent pas
recevoir de soins
depuis plusieurs jours les organisations
humanitaires réclame une trêve pour
pouvoir acheminer des médicaments et du
matériel médical qui font cruellement
défaut
il ya du droit international humanitaire
qui n'est absolument pas appliquée
depuis quatre mois dans la goutte n ya
que deux convois à chaque fois encore
comme je vous le disais tout ce qui est
équipement médical chirurgical est
enlevé et bien le dernier
un des deux était il ya une dizaine de
jours le 12 février et bien l'entrepôt a
aussi été touché il n'y a pas que les
établissements médicaux qui sont visés
qui se porte parole de l'hôpital
régional
les ambulances sont aussi des cibles
elles ne peuvent pas rouler sans essuyer
des tirs et bombardements ont contraint
plusieurs des quelques 400 mille
habitants du secteur à creuser des abris
de fortune sous leur maison pour se
mettre à l'abri
ici frédéric nicoloff radio canada
montréal